for me the starting on this journey on
irrational behavior started from
actually being in a hospital so quite a
few years ago I got injured in an
explosion I got burned in about seventy
percent of my body and as a consequence
i spent about three years in hospital
the first few months in the in the burn
department were particularly painful and
one of the particularly difficult things
was what's called the bath treatment so
everybody had a bandaid on and you take
it off and it's always a little bit
painful imagine that there is no skin
whatsoever and it's not a small band aid
but it covers seventy percent of your
body that's a long process and
incredibly painful so during the
procedure the nurses would would put me
on a stretcher and would lower me into a
bath full of iodine water that would
stink to start with and then they would
go ahead and rip the bandages off one by
one for about an hour and and during
that process I would have debates over
over weeks about what is the best way to
do it here I was experiencing this
incredible pain and what I wanted to do
was to minimize it so I would have
arguments with them about what's the
right way to trade off the intensity at
each moment in the duration so think
about it should you have a shorter
experience with a high momentary
intensity or should you have a lower
momentary tensity carrying the bandages
slower but having longer duration should
you start from the least painful and
move to the most painful or do the
opposite does it matter should you give
people breaks and not or not breaks and
I had my own intuitions about what's the
best way to give me the least pain and
the nurses had a different intuition but
given the fact that I was a patient and
there were the nurses they were deciding
what to do and when I got out of the
hospital and I learned a little bit
about the experimental method I decided
to test what's the right way so I
created lab experiments in which i will
bring people in and i would hurt them
for longer durations and lower
intensities at higher intensities
decreasing increasing with breaks
without breaks and after each experience
i would ask people how painful was this
so which
one of these two panes would you prefer
to repeat again and so now we try to
infer how people actually aggregate his
pain if you have an experience at last
over time the change in intensity at the
end of it how do you think about the
whole experience and and to my surprise
the nurses were wrong what does it mean
that their intuition that having the
treatment being relatively short let's
say an hour and tearing bandages one
after the other was the right approach
they thought that high spikes and high
intensity and duration was the way to go
it turns out it was wrong it was much
better to have a lower intensity and
longer duration not to have spikes it
also turns out you can be better to
start from the most painful part and go
down over time it would have been good
to have breaks and when I came back to
present this to them it struck me that
these were really kind wonderful people
they gave their life to to their patient
I mean this was not something that you
would unless you hit felt like a mission
this is not a job that you would choose
and at the same time they were wrong and
even though they had vast experience and
the best intention in the world they
were still very wrong and I started
wondering about what other cases are
there where people have experienced and
good intentions but are still
fundamentally wrong and that kind of
opened my eyes to look at many things in
which people are good well-meaning but
still fundamentally wrong